the Joe Rogan experience I feel like
there's a real movement towards what you
guys are doing though I feel like it's
the future because I feel like people
are fed up with that Chris Cuomo [ __ ]
they're fed up with that Rachel Maddow
[ __ ] and no disrespect to either one of
those those people but like I was with
Chris chrome was doing some thing in the
day and I was watching him where he's
basically justifying riots
yeah and I was like oh man did someone
write this for you is this how you
really feel did you think this out for
this I think all I could get from that
is Trump needs to be removed from office
so let's come up with some sort of a
reason why he's responsible for these
riots and these riots are good and these
rides have been historically done when
people feel powerless and weak that's
all true I look it's it's a terrible
position to be a young person right now
and this is what you see when you're
seeing looting you seen a lot of these
[ __ ] young white kids that have
probably not a political thought and
they're [ __ ] dopey heads and they
just run in to get free Nikes and that's
really what's going on yeah I've watched
about a hundred videos of people looting
I might have seen for black people it's
all white kids stealing sneakers so it's
kind of amazing right and this is I mean
this is what really gets me which is
that this is a pro George Floyd's family
has come out and said please stop
violence qts I mean how many times you
see that
well you never Rodney King yeah can we
all get along and I think I think that's
like that peace understanding who and
why is important to understanding what
to do right because if it's just what I
have seen hasn't just been you know in
terms of looting I don't know
specifically but I think it's very easy
to say oh it's just this type of person
it's just that type of person and to
take out of it any of the sort of like
more radical not just smashing up stores
and that kind of stuff but like graffiti
and more you know defying curfews and
those sorts of things and so if if you
view the problem is just like violent
profile intestacy have to deal with that
then that merits one response and that's
the direction the Trump is going in is
like call in the military which i think
is [ __ ] scary like calling in active
do
military in every city in the country
like we saw with the protesters who got
you know the tear gas and rubber bullets
in front of the White House or
peacefully protest I mean that [ __ ] to
me is scary and frankly the fact that
Democrats and quote-unquote journalists
on TV have acted like the world is
ending
every time Trump does anything when he
does do something like invoke the
insurrection act and say we're looking
at sending the military into American
cities there is no more language of this
is unprecedented this is outrageous this
is you know different than what we've
seen in the past left because they've
burned that up once the critical thing
that that Trump has ever done they have
cried you that's exactly the case
because I do think that this is a very
different and very dangerous and
volatile moment but if you think that
the protests are about the the structure
of a system that doesn't allow any
redress for you know problems that
people have been peacefully protesting
about for a long [ __ ] time and not a
thing has been done if you think the
protests are about you know political
system that will offer you the
quote-unquote choice of Donald Trump
who's like the Central Park five dude
and red lighting with his daddy and
denying black people housing and
Charlottesville's find people on both
sides versus Joe Biden who wrote the 94
crime bill is unrepentant for it
it was justifying against with
Charlamagne just recently and saying
Hillary's wrong apologize it for it
etcetera etcetera who as part of this
whole thing went out and said it you
know police shouldn't be shooting people
in the heart and said they should shoot
him in the leg like train him to do that
like when you look at those two choices
choices this that's right if you
understand that as the legitimate part
of the protest then your response is
going to be very different than it's
just like oh these are bad people these
are people which además terrorists we
have to crack down on them let's call in
the military that [ __ ] ultimately never
works because look at 19 years in
Afghanistan what do we learn yeah you
can take the ground
you can't hold it you can't hold a
society together with an aggressive
militarized response that's not gonna
work over time so if that's your only
strategies like okay then what
then what are you going to do or we have
curfews at 1:00 p.m. every day or you
have militaries holding down American
cities every day because you have a
significant chunk of the population that
will no longer consent
[Applause]